good morning John isn't me or her baby
who's been crazy boring lately and don't
think that I do enough jump cuts anymore
my friends you are correct this should
be a John Green day but it is not I
thought it's a hankering day hello
everyone I've taken this particular John
Green Tuesday in exchange for John doing
the next two Tuesday's in a row and for
getting John Green a professional New
York Times bestselling author to
proofread the first section of my novel
which I just finished the first section
not the whole novel but that's exciting
anyway I mean I managed to write like a
hundred and fifty pages of this book now
I get a professional author to proofread
it for me is it Brotherhood fantastic
John on Thursday you brought back the
evil baby orphanage in yes it is true we
have some very large differences of
opinion of how the evil baby orphanage
should be approached more as a story
than as an actual entity John what's
there to be well-known evil babies of
the evil baby orphanage so like he wants
evil baby Stalin an evil baby Hitler and
he wants all these people interacting
the modern with that is if you've got
all the evil babies in the evil baby
orphanage what is the world still suck
so much which is why from my personal
perspective I'm much more intrigued by
the idea that there is an evil baby
orphanage out there already and the guy
who created it is just too busy and out
of his mind trying to fix the world in
all these ways but this is currently
what we're living in right now the best
that he can do but that of course is
neither here nor there because John you
asked the nerdfighters to create a time
machine I've been thinking about
precisely how that might be done there
are two major problems with time travel
first if you do what you have the
possibility of creating grandfather
paradox which might unravel the universe
it would suck the grandfather paradox of
course being that if I go back and get
my grandfather then how did he die
because I was never born that just seems
like a loophole that the universe
wouldn't allow the second problem with
time travel is that if it was possible
why don't we ever see any time travelers
I want to come back to the dawn of the
information age and watch the decline of
television and the rise of YouTube I
mean that's exactly where I want to be
anywhere in history right here there are
several types of time travel that would
exclude the grandfather paradox and
explain why we aren't always inundated
by time tourists the first of these is
the easiest way of time traveling and we
all can do it together right now now
what I want you to do is look right here
right around there
you my friend are traveling forward in
time at one second per second oh I just
blew my own mind the problem is making
the
Oh backwards or forwards faster turns
out making it go forwards faster isn't
even all that difficult you just have to
move really fast unfortunately I don't
think that that was fast enough and now
I have a little bit of a take but if you
could go really fast like close to the
speed of light fast then suddenly you
experience time is traveling at the same
rate but relative to other people your
time is traveling much more slowly fans
of science fiction and literature will
know all the frick about this but if you
take an interstellar journey at near the
speed of light
by the time you get to your destination
maybe only a couple of years will pass
for you but tens or hundreds or even
thousands of years could pass with the
rest of the universe unfortunately this
doesn't actually help us travel
backwards in time only forwards in time
and only sort of kinda a little bit
doesn't even help us travel forward in
time but there is a way to use that
phenomenon - then bridge the place
that's forward in time and the place
that's back in time basically you create
a wormhole which we don't actually know
how to do but many people say that it is
theoretically possible so you create
this wormhole which bridges two places
in the universe then you take what are
the ends of that wormhole and you move
it very fast it close to the speed of
light now for that into the wormhole
time is traveling very very slowly but
for the other end of the wormhole time
is traveling at absolutely normal speeds
so then the end of the process you stop
the wormholes and suddenly if you enter
one end of the wormhole you either come
out dead or you come out back in time
but if I created the time machine today
I couldn't go back in time to kill my
grandfather because I could only go back
to today forever I could go back to
today but I could never go back any
further than that and so my friends for
the evil baby orphanage this means that
every day the universe spends without a
time machine is another day that evil
babies will be free to do their evil on
our world shoot please in comments let
me know if there are other opportunities
for backwards time travel and I would
really like to hear whether you're on
John's side or my side of the evil baby
orphanage to bake should they be
historical evil babies or non historical
evil babies everyone will see me
tomorrow with my song Wednesday song
dftba